[Music]
ah
you are looking at the undisputed
greatest middleweight in the world at
presence
who can stop that man
i'm looking for your chill sonnen i'm
looking for someone who literally puts
his finger in your chest and puts you
under some pressure because someone
needs to have that self-belief and i'm
not saying it from anyone
still all disputed
called you out that's a guy that
definitely i'd like to fight he will
bring in a lot of eyes he's the guy that
would exactly do what you said he has
the self belief that's how it all starts
yeah and those are the ones who are
crazy enough to make it happen i was in
the nose bleach and now i made his nose
bleed i'm a petty [__] when
jordan in the last thing goes and i took
that personally that's me they said i'll
have no knockout power
i'm gonna talk about the dark side like
there's a place i have to go to like my
mom has accepted it now she uh she
understands like three weeks after the
fight if i'm not picking up her calls
don't take it personal huge right for
autism
i feel like i'm going to war wow what a
fight get the bonus checks ready yeah
i'm in london town [__] the things
what's the paintings like
is that a thing you had any luck with
the ladies are you struggling i think
you could be struggling
it's hard to find people who who really
want you
i guess for you and also have someone
who doesn't want to compete with you
it's not a competition you're trying to
be it's not a competition i'm the child
because first of all you lose
what was the last thing a girl did that
you thought
you would be different you care give a
[__] everyone watching at home i love
you all hey shout out to the puppy
life after fighting the thing is i
actually just want to start a family
that's me well yeah for me i just don't
want to have all this [__] to deal with
when i when i when i do that i want to
be able to be like what do you want to
do today and just do whatever the [__]
he or she wants to do that day
welcome back to the true journey podcast
sponsored by jim shark today is guest
it's the legend the middleweight
champion of the world israel adasanja
one day a legend one day still working i
think you're there like i'm on my way
but you're still working you're getting
compared to silva a lot
i've been doing this this is my first
fight i said this when i jumped in the
ufc i was like because there's a lot of
oh he's like silver 2.0 this and that
and i was like just give it time those
comparisons will fade away
and they did especially after i fought
them but i feel like
i do hear those rumblings now because of
how many title defenses i have five
title defenses and i'm just like racking
them up but i'm like ah
because i'm still in it you know they
say you can't see the forest for the
trees but i'm
i know where i want to be but i just
feel like let me just work just stay
tuned until i'm done and then we can be
like right now
this is what you want to say about him
this is what you want to say about him i
feel like it's it's unfair as well
because like we always romanticize the
old guys of the past yeah so like when
jsp was in his prime everyone's like
well is he really matt hughes you know
like and now with uzman everyone's like
well there's no jsp exactly and it's
like this these smashing guys yes we
never did that
but
that we have so much love for the the
old guys that you're never quite gonna
get that but i think the fact that you
fought him
and
now you're doing things that i think the
fact that you went up and fought for the
title he never did that like even you
you went for it and even though it
didn't quite come off you were very
close yeah um you went up before 205 a
couple of times james irving and
like foreign champions yeah i understand
i mean but you're saying with jsp even
gsp his last few fights you know i
remember just the narrative was always
just like oh he's boring he's boring
he's this and that i'm just like are you
[__] kidding me and this is me i was
never like because i was always a silver
guy so i was never the biggest gsp so
stan but i respected his skills and i
was a fan of his fighting style still
so i think the one that made me really
take notice and be like okay this guy is
legit was the carlos conded fight how he
took that head kick and then came back
and then dominated carlos i was just
like yo
you have to give it up the boring thing
you're getting a bit of criticism now
because
you had the most entertaining fights and
almost to like an unattainable level of
maintain like like people are going to
watch so much film on you
and they're going to adapt their style
how are you finding that criticism see i
kind of feel like um
to bring you know well silva when he
fought talis latest ufc 97
i remember after that five people were
just like oh
silva's boring here's this he's that but
he fought talia's latest who was a jiu
jitsu black belt who was elite
but then he wasn't able to do what he
normally did to everyone with silver you
know and people then
just said ah silva's
washed he's trash
and then he came back ufc 101 and then
starch forest griffin in a spectacular
fashion people were just like oh it's
always recently biased same thing
happened with me after my romero fight
people were like oh he just runs he's
this is i'm like are you [__] kidding
me that was right off the back of three
like amazing fights exactly and i was
like after what i've done for you [__]
that's not gonna pay me so then for me i
came back with the with the cost of
fight and i did what i did so it's
always recently biased with this fight i
felt um
i wanted to do better than i did because
of how i beat him the first time i i
knew what i could have done to him and
in the first round i was on my way there
i still haven't watched the fight but
when i do i'll be able to give you an
honest assessment but the way i feel i
know i won that fight clearly i know i
won that fight and i know yeah it was
close in certain rounds but i know i won
that fight he apparently his corner was
telling him in between rounds you're
losing this fight you need to do the
dirt so i'm like well how the [__] you
think you're winning a fight for corners
telling you you're losing the fight yeah
you know but um so for me i have to
watch that fight again because my
cameraman jeff
hinted at it to me about how i
approached fights with different people
and there was
there was something different with this
fight than than
the first fight
and to be honest to friend to tell you
what it is it was just a static
the way he approached me in this fight
the first fight he was cheeky
he was being a little smart ass
you know he thought he he thought you
know well israel's not as good as he
thinks he is and i was like i'll give
[__] i'll show you and he was a little
bit
cocky in his own way
this fight he had none of that he came
in humble sombra cause i already whipped
his ass
even there was a bit when i first
entered the the octagon i did my circle
around around the octagon and then when
i was when i was kind of skipping past
him he puts his hand out
and then i slapped it like almost
reluctantly like what the [__] you want
to shake my hand for we're about to
fight like i don't
i don't like that
uh it's and i said this is just me
riffing right now i don't know if i ah
[__] i'm just riffing but like
i want to know what it's like to fight
someone even without static and still be
able to just take them out with that
killer instinct because that's one thing
my guy jeff has said is like you realize
that it's whenever you have
beef with someone you don't really like
someone you have this different this
different venom when you fight them
and yeah i'm gonna tap into that that's
something i'm gonna work on for myself
some homework i feel like silva was very
good at that we were talking about him
earlier like um
he he literally ripped the piss out of
people right there in the middle of that
octagon yeah even if they were
respectful like the way he humiliated
forrest griffin when everyone liked
forrest yeah it really made you go
yeah you don't want to [__] get near
him and and you have that in your
toolbox no doubt about it but in this
fight i felt like robert he didn't
approach you with the real belief that
he could win yeah like
and to me
i watched both fights back to back last
night and i thought yeah all right he
did worse in it ended worse for him in
the first fight but i respected that
first fight a lot more because he was
fighting with pure he's trying to win he
fought with belief that he could win
yeah and and to me beating you
it's like um
you're uh you ever seen batman
the dark knight rises right but he jumps
across and he can only you can only win
when there's no rope yes and you have to
fight you the same way like you're no
plan you're not gonna
you're not gonna beat israel out of
sanya without actually risking you
getting knocked out and that's what
robert never did in this fight he he
fought he fought smart but he fought
with this thing of i don't want to lose
more than he wanted to win exactly and
with you victoria did that as well yeah
of course that's why both fights were
boring in the eyes of the fans is
because you just pick these guys apart
with quite easily with those leg kicks
and beat them up but it wasn't as
devastating as before
because they those guys weren't
committing exactly something like i said
we were silver right into um
in ufc 97 with telus letters and even uh
ufc 90 that was the one with uh patrick
cortez people were like oh
you know he's not he's not taking them
out the same way this and there but it's
like no these guys aren't trying they're
trying to survive they're not trying to
win they're trying not to lose and
there's a difference in that when when
the guy is like
you know not willing to take the risk
and i take risks i take calculated risks
but then when i'm up and i was really
i mean i gave him ptsd in the first
round and one thing i regret not doing
is asking my corner or even looking at
the looking at the screen because i
i didn't want to look at the past that's
what i told him in the first fight when
i was like don't look at the screen look
at me i'm right now but i wish i'd asked
my corner like
what did i drop him with
because then they would have told me
left hand you were southpaw
boom i can work off that but i just
think i i don't know
in the moment i was just like ah [__]
you know don't worry about that let's
focus on touching him and doing what we
do stick to the game plan
and
yeah last time i called the audible we
had a game plan but i was kind of like
i'm not really feeling it in the moment
so i called audible and we had we just
fought on the fly
this time
the southpaw i was feeling really good
southpaw even in the second third i was
feeling really good south but
comfortable but i was like uh let's just
stick to the game plan so i went back to
the game plan and i wished i trusted my
instinct more because if i had known
there was a southpaw 2 that dropped him
i would have felt way more comfortable
south but like i already was but i just
went back to the game plan because i was
like okay let's stick to the game plan
and get to it was a great shot that
dropped him i don't know if you remember
oh i saw i've seen the highlights yeah
because
he's got a good guard and you come right
through that middle precision and things
it felt like nothing yeah that's why i
was i was like did that oh did i drop
him off yeah okay
it didn't look like your hardest shot
for sure just i don't hit hard like i
said it was a sharp
speed and just just that precision when
i when i find a way to get get through
that guard and just poop and i see i've
seen the shot as well from different
angles and it was right down the middle
so
yeah my one regret is definitely i wish
i'd just been like what dropped them and
then not no you know when guy's like oh
i'll drop them and then that's why you
see them throw for the next that's not
me yeah i wouldn't have done that but i
just didn't want to focus on the past so
i was like let me focus on right now but
that would have been a smart thing to do
but in hindsight you know you learn this
is this is part of the game you learn
yeah i notice when when you go southpaw
you have this thing where you sort of
keep your hand out and then you hit them
with that leg kick every time you love
the lower leg kick and southpaw i
destroyed them with the second leg kick
i believe like on the third one i
remember he just picked his leg up
different i was like ooh that's hurting
that's already really hurting so he was
he was primed he was ready for it
and that's why for me myself i'm i mean
i won the fight i know i did but
that's why i'm kind of just like because
i just i expected better of myself and i
know people are criticizing me but trust
me i don't give a [__] what they say
it's about what i say about myself
that's why i haven't watched the fight
yet so i'll watch it when i want to
watch it and i'll be like right let me
have an honest look at this fight
and see where could i have improved
better you know and like i said silver
ran into this problem you know people
talk [__] about him and also
his performances and whatnot but then he
always found a way and i i think i know
how to tap into that in my own way so
that's one
one thing i'm grateful for is my my
insight my objectivity just to be able
to sit down and just be like let me have
an honest look at this and see how i can
improve better and yeah i want to do
just that that's quite amazing that
you've got that attitude because
obviously you've had so many kickboxing
matches you've got boxing matches mma
fights and you're still trying to grow
you talk about um calculated risks and
when
i was actually watched your fight with a
boxer who uh was like an olympic level
boxer he he was on about how shocked he
was at your style because
he's like god this guy leans right back
at the waist chin in the air to him he's
like i can't believe he gets away with
this but then i'm like yeah but watch
because you come with these hooks and
obviously that's how you finish them in
the first fight but
this time he was catching you a little
bit with that jab yeah he changed it up
from a double jab to a triple jab and
yeah kind of like okay
that gave me a little bit of a shine on
this side he was fainting a little bit
too yeah a little bit in the later
rounds and then
i can't remember i it didn't throw me
off in the weather i was like oh [__] i
need to oh [__] i still i still went
back at him i remember i jabbed him up a
couple of times from what i recalled and
i went back to the leg kicks but
yeah
in time i just have to watch that tip
and just kind of like i said break it
down properly what what do you feel next
for you after after that fight jared i
want jared next that excites me rob
excited me don't get me wrong
the the exciting part about facing rob
again was
the prospect of beating him worse than
the first time and i was really held i
was hell sent on that man i was like i
gotta really help him out there's
certain moments that i'll pick that no
one else would know no one else would
know apart from me and rob or just me
and i'd be like that was the moment that
was the moment i [__] that up damn and
i'll kick myself for it but then
yeah
um but i want jared next i like the idea
of having like
a new opponent someone
fresh exactly someone that can give me
i've set jared up before to fight me um
but he he didn't rise to the occasion in
that fight and then now this is his time
he rose to the occasion before at the
way as i said to him i was like look
please take this bum out just so i can
get someone new and he's like bro i'm
trying to get this fight i'm like
[__] me too it'd be good to fight you
and i'm a man of my words so yeah he
gets the next shot you've had a lot of
rematches already um
and then um
darren till didn't quite happen
unfortunately we would have loved that
in the uk i would love that here in the
o2 that would be [__] awesome blow
the roof off that thing yeah didn't
happen
but um we've uh literally we're
literally like we're looking for um your
i'm looking for your channel sonnen i'm
looking for someone who literally puts
his finger in your chest and puts you
under some pressure because the thing
i'm i'm looking at even with uh jared
and
a few of these other guys is
do any of them really
want to act like i'm going to beat this
guy because they're all so aware of how
good you are now i feel like they i
we've said earlier they're coming in to
survive and i just don't think that's
enough to beat you like someone has to
really
to elevate your star as well we need
that rivalry that aldo mcgregor yeah
anderson i agree i think someone needs
to have that self-belief and i'm not
saying it from anyone i think if darren
had have continued winning he would have
he would have come in strong but
obviously that didn't happen so
um yet there's still time yeah
i think there is time for him yeah he's
training with um
chemiev
uh chimayab's called you out um tremiya
was talking about becoming a triple
champion he hasn't even won a single
belt yet what do you think of this guy i
don't have to take him seriously till i
have to take him seriously
and
that's a guy that definitely i'd like to
fight if he does what he says he wants
to do because guess what
he will bring in a lot of eyes he's the
guy that would exactly do what you said
and just like this that right right he
has the self belief even if it's
for all where you know at this point it
could be delusion because we've seen
that's how it all starts yeah and those
are the ones who are crazy enough to
make it happen and he's on his way but
show me something first show me
something that will make me his last
fight made me take notice that was the
one i was like ooh i know how jing
aliyang is he's good
you know he's not like him
beautifully beautifully and i was like
yo there was something he did in that
fight i won't i won't give it away but i
was i was like
i like that i was really impressed with
so that's what made me take notice of
him properly but
at the moment still it's just blocking
in the wind because who's he fought at
and i'm not saying he can't look he can
beat a lot of these guys at 185 a lot of
the top guys from what i've heard but
let me see it first and then we'll start
talking before all this
on
all this hype around you yeah he's got a
lot of hype for someone who hasn't had
like that many fights yet and i think
that's the thing skills skills in the in
the gift of the gab he knows how to run
this mouth yeah he sounds like a crazy
person yeah nah we all do at some point
well i like that i know i like it like
you said a guy like chill something that
got it like yeah put their finger in
your chest and because i like that when
someone brings that out of me as well
like costa when someone when someone
really because i'm a nice guy i chill
i'm real
i mean country to popular believe i'm
very i'm very laid back in my own but
then when someone brings that out of me
that that shadow self i like to i like
to step into it i like to tap into that
and let them bring that forth because
then they get to play with the real me
you know what i mean that's a scarier
version of you for sure but i mean but
before that i can still i mean
this fight just the robert like you know
even at the press conference he gave me
nothing to play with he was just like
well
we'll have a good fight you know
i think that shows where his state of
mind was like i didn't want to [__]
wake up the beast here exactly he knew
he knew because last time i i was
i'm i'm a petty [__] you know i
am petty we've seen and and i'm like you
know when jordan in the last thing goes
and i took that personally
that's me mate when you bend [__] um
foster costa rosa
yeah that was like prison rules jesus
like
that was as humiliating
that's like me being
freestyling he was just there i'm the
big dog in the yard now so what does the
big dog do when he wants to show
dominance even the female dog does it
just you know let him know double tap
because
you you talk about that spite and that's
that's what we love as fight fans
someone who's nasty and that's why we
love mike tyson and when you jumped on
top of the cage after you beat with a
guy the first time
you immediately pointed family first my
family was right there blew them kisses
and i was like you costa [__] you a
piece of [__] and he starts talking all
this [__] with his ricky martin
sorry i keep i keep using rick martin as
like
this is a nice guy he's got his
beautiful [__] he does look like
him a little bit yeah so i just i just
use that sorry ricky but yeah um then i
started going at him and all this [__]
but that was i guess me setting the
fight up already i even also i was in
flagrant two the other day in new york
and i i they played back a clip where i
said early on like i want to fight this
guy you know when everyone was thinking
like he was this
adonis put him on a pedestal and i was
saying i want to fight this guy i'm
going to [__] him up i feel like that's
the same thing with um chimaya right now
everyone's doing the same thing and just
riding off that and that's
due credit to him
but i like when people wake that side of
me up it's in there i know it's in there
my dark side but i just never tap into
it because i can't live in that in that
place for too long if not it'll consume
me and when it consumes me it starts to
seep over into my i guess regular life
do you become a bit more uh bad things
happen like bad tempered and irritable
uh
i'm just
i'm just not as me to be around not as
fun to be around put it that way yeah i
just you can't you can't redline it all
the time i can't be this guy who's
always just angry at the world and just
like
you know i want to fight everyone i want
static because then you just attract
[__] into your life trust me i've
been there i've been in the guy who
stays in that shadow self and just like
always looking for something because
then guess what you'll find i know i'm
very good at manifesting so if i stay in
that headspace too often and i'm always
looking for a fight and i have to this
is why
i don't have to be this alpha guy who
tries to like you know you know those
guys you know you come you come in the
room and they shake your hand and try
and like i don't try any of that i don't
have to prove how tough i am you know
that's why i can have french tips
you know you've got lovely nails in it
thank you very sexy first time i got
these man i got distracted with them
every time i texted every time what kind
of watch is that as a rolly [__] me yeah
it's god almighty that's beautiful
presidential might get another one when
i go back to l.a you're living the good
life right now i'm enjoying myself this
is all before the new [__] deal by
the way this is all before the new year
yeah this looks like people think like
this is nigga's not saying oh he's done
this now i'm like no this is all before
the new deal i get well looked after
like financially because i have one of
the smartest men i know with money
behind me and that's my father he is
helping me learn how to flip my money
the right way so that way i
you know i'm put on gaming at the same
time i can stay stay ahead of the game i
don't want to be in uh one of these bad
statistics you hear about when it comes
to athletes and i never will be knocking
wood well we we have something in common
because as soon as i got money i bought
a mclaren too hey um but uh i saw mine
because the taxman needed somebody
but uh yeah i'm knocking when i say that
i was like that's my guy right there how
are you enjoying the colors
of course yeah 720 years i call them
kurama it's named after the nine-tailed
demon face uh fox from naruto
so um yeah it just somehow went to the
store i kind of made them and
lamborghini bit against each other wow
because in my head so coming up as a kid
i always i i had this vision of our like
a batmobile i wanted a matte black
aventador
lamborghini but then when i got inside i
could only sit like this tall
i couldn't i couldn't fully sit up
properly unless i took the roof off but
then the mclaren i could sit up yeah
it's weird properly in the legs your
legs are right the way though exactly so
then i was like but then i kind of said
i don't know man i'm looking at this
lamborghini next door and i go to the
lamborghini i was like i don't know man
i'm looking at this mclaren next door so
i made them have a little bit of a
bidding war
and i was going to pick the mclaren
anyway because i just i fit better in
there still love that car i still write
it but i just write it i write it
on my days when i'm feeling myself you
know if i'm like if i'm not in the mood
that day i don't want to be stared at i
don't drive that car i drive my low key
car yeah it's not a car for anxiety
that's for sure when you're actually the
worst yeah if you don't want to be
looked at yeah i'm just like right just
i'm taking reptar out today
do you ever have anxiety or anything
like that of course yeah everyone does
there's a spectrum of
there's a spectrum of you know
anxiousness some people
have say just critical crippling anxiety
yeah there's zero and there's those who
feel nothing
of that sort but i feel like we all just
depending on where we are in life we can
kind of like i always say this if you
don't look after your physical health
what's gonna happen you're gonna get
physically ill
same thing with your mental health so we
all we all have the spectrum of our
physical health and we all like to be
balanced here in zero but then if you're
feeling really good putting on the right
feeling your body you're gonna lean on
this side but then you start like you
know putting the wrong [__] in your body
and not looking after yourself you're
gonna go
this side so same thing with our mental
health
and yeah these days the last time i can
remember was
in the last year somewhere i was just
driving
i felt it was a nice day i thought you
know dropped up therapy i hop in the car
and then before i knew it i was driving
and i was just like
[__]
there's everyone looking at me and i
just i'll just put the roof up i put the
roof up and then
it happened to be a traffic jam on the
motorway and i was just like
[__] and i'm just in there and i can
just feel you just feel it yeah and then
sometimes it's not even real though as
well yeah i'm sure that it is you as
well yeah now but i can you know you can
feel it when people are looking at you
and i'm just like and what's not it's
not even them looking at me it's for me
at that time
i remember as just a perception and i'm
bigger than that i'm better than that
but where my headspace was it was just
the perception like
uh what's that person thinking what's
that person thinking i'm just like i
just want to go home and then someone
will beep up and like hey stop in there
or you're driving hey
and i'm a big fan i've been like hey
what's up man thank you yeah and i i
just had this not a scalp i just had
this like look at my face but i'm just
like oh just get me home it's weird
though because to me anxiety kind of
comes out of uh
what gets you anxious uh
i think uh the idea of going outside
when i've been in a lot well not because
we work in here for hours and hours and
hours sometimes really and then i'm like
i just don't want to go out have you
been inside like
uh no no no no
my dad was a lot and his dad was yeah
i'm sorry i don't know that's chris yeah
i definitely have that definitely don't
want to go prison feel yeah but um yeah
but with you i guess people see you as
this fearless guy who literally does one
of the most insane jobs ever so the idea
that you would have those same feelings
is quite i mean something yeah exactly
i'm human like certain things get me
anxious same thing so
we've had this whole
[__] now with covid right so um
after the costa fight we we go back home
we have to quarantine for two weeks
um in the managed isolation facility or
whatever i've been only lucky to do four
my coach usually has done like nine of
them jesus so you know he'd go corner
alex folkanowski for a title flight come
back home go into one of these managed
isolation places for two weeks and then
get out see his family's kids at the gym
blah blah blah and have another one of
us fight maybe me or i don't know kai
[__] off again come back and he's done
it nine times
i'll tell you one thing i kind of like
them only for the fact that after the
fight i get to just be alone for a
little bit but then when i get out i
just i it's too much for me so i get out
what do you do to prisoners when you
want to punish them you isolate them so
this is manage isolation
and then when i get out i just because
people don't care that oh my god esri
stop and oh my god and they just come at
you
with like level 10 energy and i'm just
at a two or three idling i'm just like
hey what's up man one thing i learned
now an epiphany i had before the first
rob fight was i don't have to match
people's energy
because back in the day you don't want
to disappoint them right exactly i feel
like oh if if i didn't match the energy
it would be a [__] experience for them
but i'm like i don't care
like my piece is more important for me
so if you think this is a [__]
experience because i wasn't like hey
buddy how's it going
you know like then that's on you
so for me i realize i don't have to
match anyone's energy so if someone's
going somewhere and doing something you
shouldn't stop that like for example i
was on the way into a train and this guy
was like can i get a photo i was going
to miss the train i'm like if you can
run with me and take a photo we're good
but i'm not stopping exactly even at the
airport like people but people don't
care what do they want they want to take
they want to take and it's like nah
there's only so much i can give it's
only and the rest is for me and those
who really matter to me but then if you
give so much to the and that i've seen
it happens it's so many like actresses
actors athletes musicians
where they give so much of people like
you know they built the like society
builds you up on a pedestal just to tear
you down and i've seen it happen to so
many people but i'm like i'm never going
to be one of those statistics so yeah i
only give so much that i can afford to
give and the rest is for me to do with
and if people are like oh but we
we're fans with this and i'm like and
a lot of people just they're fans but a
lot of people just lie about that [__] a
lot of people are even fans just to
watch you fail they want to see a train
the the crane the you know the crash the
train wreck you know so half of your
followers on instagram probably want to
see you 100 uh that's right so we've
been i've followed you since i'm like
bro my biggest haters followed me
of course so it doesn't really mean
anything it's not like i'm being an
[__] or i'm being disingenuous so i
don't like
i don't appreciate what they do sorry
excuse me i always have to burp i know i
don't
i don't um it's not like i don't i don't
i don't appreciate the real fans and
stuff like that but i was like no if i'm
having dinner with my close friends and
family
i don't
you expecting me to get up from this
table squeeze past all these people to
take a photo with you
is selfish
i feel it's like you know i just observe
like oh he's with his family in a deep
moment right now let me just leave him
be let me just let me just enjoy it
because i've seen that i've also been
that person i've just i've done the
opposite as well and i've realized like
[__] this is when i was younger before i
had any like i guess etiquette on that
kind of stuff but now that i'm on this
side
bruh trust me it's i mean imagine if
we're having lunch right now i would
probably
without my security team i'd get stopped
like maybe we'll get stuck maybe
in 10 minutes six times
and the flow of the conversation gets
ruined gets cut off gets cut short it's
like sorry about that anyway what was i
saying
talking talking talking boom and i'm
like
cool there's a time and place for this
kind of stuff yeah i know exactly what
you mean like when i go
where i live uh with my boys who i've
known for years yeah who are just like
you know doing regular jobs i feel like
a [__] to be honest like i'm like lads
um cause they remember me from school
yeah and i feel like a dick you know
because we're taking selfies all night
with me yeah one time joey one of my
friends had the cool cat um this is a
while ago years ago where
he said do you realize there's a line of
people i'm like what do you mean because
at the club where he says you realize
like there's a lot of people just
waiting to talk to you because i don't
see it but apparently there was a line
of like 10 people
and then later on that night he's like
yeah it's not even fun to go out with
you anymore
and that one hit me that one stuck to me
because i was just like that's my boy
and he said it's not even fun to go out
with you cause all it's like we just
hang around and you just take photos
exactly yeah it's like nah they want to
hang out with me they want to enjoy my
company they're you're equal it's not
relationships yes exactly so they want
to
enjoy that and not just have to like oh
we have to wait for him to take [__]
15 photos you know so things like that i
just feel like i have to be sacred and
protected and i'll protect that at any
cost now i am not scared of setting
boundaries boundaries are big for me
even for these guys who like try and
pretend to be fans and they come to the
the the gym i'm training at and say for
example houston and like oh i'm a big
fan i'm like bro i've seen you for the
fourth time this week and you've brought
a picture every [__] time i know what
you're doing and they're trying oh i'm a
fan but yeah you might be a fan but i
know what you're doing you're selling
these well i was like i've seen your
face and then now they they know
i think someone gave me a gift on one of
the embedders or something and i really
appreciate it like oh you gave me
something thank you for that now
the next day someone oh i brought you a
gift and gave me like this sweater i was
like first off it's nike i'm a puma
focal puma and that's not even my size
but they just you know just try and find
a way to get over it that's so weird
yeah very and then
i'll do my bit but i just tell them that
i only sign one thing i'm not gonna sign
15 [__] things for you because i know
what you're doing
and it's not like it's not like i'm
selfish or whatever i don't want to give
back i have my way of giving back but in
that way it's like
i feel like it's just they're just
taking they're just taking advantage got
a [__] job man exactly thank you
because i know how much they can make
off those things not just me all the
fighters there during that week that
they get to track down and get
them to sign [__] and they'll come with
the audacity of like 20 different things
like oh can you sign this oh i'm such a
big fan and they'll have their speech
but if even when i say like i'll just
sign one of these i'll see one of them
sneak their glove to the other friend
oh then i hear when the people bring
their kids into it man because i
wouldn't say no to kids and i feel bad
because it's like this little girl does
not watch the ufc
i know she doesn't watch the u.s
she's looking like she's got no idea who
you are some of them i know when they do
and i don't know like they do watch but
the ones that just look like what the
[__] daddy
i'm like
okay sure and i don't want to make the
kid feel bad i'm like don't use your kid
as a pawn in this [__] little game
you're playing trying to escape west
over here yeah oh let's not do that
[Laughter]
man yeah but um so so fame is crazy and
and yeah you you seem really well
equipped to deal with it
i've practiced i literally had
all this
just like
drilled out of my head from the jump
like before even it all started before i
started to get manifested i just knew
like
this uh these are the trappings of fame
these are ways you can fall and there's
look the reason you've never seen me on
tmz on some crazy headline unlike some
people
there's still time knocking wood like
[__] tweet you put out the other way
you had me dying on valentine's day oh
yeah that was funny it wasn't even my
tweet someone sent it to me and i was
like oh that's funny so i posted it and
i reposted the um original as well but
yeah i mean hey you gotta share the love
right have you ever had any like really
weird experiences through being famous
like people waiting for you and stuff
like that so we walked into a club or a
bar one time and then you know there's
like probably four guys and like two
girls you know they were the center of
attention
and then
you know i get in there and the guys are
just like oh my god stop bending and
then all the attention goes on me and i
could see her from the gecko like
straight like the [__] this guy
and then
then you know they're showing me love
i'm taking pictures she comes over like
excuse me
like who are you i'm like oh don't worry
about it man i'm just killing it you
know and then
because i didn't give her the
response she wanted
she was really adamant just like you
know like yeah but like why is everyone
fending over you like who who are you i
don't really know who you are and i was
like baby i don't know who you are
either and i just
you know like pied her out the way and
then i think that like ate at her
because it was just
the [__] like this guy how dare he i was
like i don't know who you are you don't
know who i am it's fine i don't care
that you don't know who i am your boys
obviously like me and i could probably
steal them off you right now if i wanna
because i think it's just the fact that
it's an attention thing exactly she's
jealous exactly that's so weird so for
me it was just yeah that was just a way
of reminding her just like no your
[__] place [__] shut the [__] down
yeah in a nice way in the nicest way
yeah of course respectfully respectfully
shut the [__] up
um
yeah uh you were talking about uh
visualization and stuff like that that
fascinates me because
it's something that so many successful
people do and
regular people i think
they don't see the value in it
but how how does that help you in in
specific cases do you think there's
levels man this levels to the point
where in my life even right now some of
the things i've materialized
that don't have to do with fame that
just has to do with my life personally
that i'm just like how the [__] did i
get here how the [__] did i make that
happen
because
you have to be crazy almost
i have a really wild imagination so
my parents
like
you know although i i had toys and stuff
as a kid there was a certain age my dad
was kind of like right you know
academics is number one now [__] all
this place [__] all this toy [__] so
my dad didn't believe well how old were
you about five yeah yeah nigerian prince
five [__] house yeah so my dad didn't
believe in toys he believed in books
okay so as a kid and i'm dyslexic i
would be
reading
studying for like hours after school
sometimes you know come home do my
homework and i have to study for like
two hours
it got to the point after like maybe
10 15 minutes i wouldn't even be reading
the like absorbing the words on the page
i'll just be looking at the lines and
just daydreaming about something else
and i'll look at the book for the amount
of time i should have that page and turn
it look at that page for the right
amount of time and i'll just it just
became a habit and not just be in my
head
on some wild adventures that happened
that day or that what tomorrow might
being or just
whatever i just create whatever i wanted
in my head
and that's one thing people forget is
that you can create whatever you want i
can create any reality that i want and i
have it doesn't just happen like that
overnight but it's just this
constant it's a it's like drilling it's
like drilling when you constantly
manifest it goes to the point that it
just becomes second nature my mclaren
having a sports car
when i was driving my my teammate's car
uh blood diamond he moved to china right
so i didn't have a car he lent me his
car it was this beat up honda
it was a stick shift a manual so
whenever i would drive it and
i would shift the the gear from one to
two or two to three
i'd i'd shift and i just do this
all right yeah i do this
and it just became second nature yeah
because i was i was manifesting having a
sports car one day i don't even use the
pedal shifts unless i want to drop shift
once in a while and then i'm gonna
[__] know that you just set it on
automatically yeah barley once in a
while i just drop drop drop
but yeah um but that was me just doing
all that just to like
put it out there in the universe and get
my body ready for it and just really
visualize it it gets to the point like
my walkout this this this past weekend
when i got to the arena i did my
my walk on the ring announcement and all
that i visualized it when i was doing
that walk out i
it was just it was just like okay i
could see everything it was empty arena
but i could feel everything and i saw
where the people were and the signs and
the hands and security
the prep point i knew where everyone's
gonna be
and
yeah it just gets to the point that it's
just you you look crazy doing it because
i'm dapping imaginary people up
you know but in my head i'm making it
happen the brain doesn't realize what's
real and what's not real
are you good at shadow boxing for this
reason
yeah like i can shadow box and when i'm
shadow boxing you almost think i'm
fighting someone invisible because i'm
i'm literally dodging their attacks
i'm taunting them i'm letting them know
what's up and i'm talking as well even
fight week whenever uh like maybe on
thursday
yeah that's the last hard training last
training before the fight really just to
cut weight which isn't it but then like
eugene has a shadow box for five minutes
at the end and just visualize even
hasn't it i find that quite difficult
myself like yeah because i would need
like start boxing a couple of years ago
and i'm not feeling like i feel like a
damn fool here what the hell am i doing
walking around yeah i throw punches at
no one but like the best fighters that i
i watch
they do look like that and this is the
weird thing is people forget a martial
art is an art and you were in there
creating exactly and i feel like the
best strikers especially ceo you know
i'm not really that clued up on the choo
choo game by comparison but
the strikers like mcgregor i've heard
him say time and time again i'm creating
in there that's the difference between
me and these other guys the times that
they're they're doing what they drilled
but like what you were to say at the
start the podcast about how i wish i'd
just been more fluent and creative and
rather than stick with a game plan yeah
like there's a balance of doing that and
sticking to the game plan but i was on
the game plan it was working but then
when i deviated from the game plan a
little bit
and that was working
you know that's what dropped him i
should i should have just been like
right trust my instinct because i did it
the first time i fought him i was like
oh this is working better i'm going to
stick with this and my corner trusts me
enough wholeheartedly to know like okay
we can
we can just create as we this is we can
create a game plan on the fly yep and we
still have the plan a to fall back on
but i was just adamant like oh you know
what let me just stick with planning on
this one you know but yeah it's about
creating moments it's about creating an
art like a
a masterpiece a moment in there and
honestly if you shadowbox the right way
when you start to like get into that
zone
you you almost feel like you have to
almost
i guess be crazy in a way you just have
to like suspend your belief of what
reality is and just standing there i'm
just walking them down like what's up
pop pop pop moving out the way sprawling
sometimes i'll take a few hits just just
to mimic it and then your brain doesn't
know man honestly your brain had because
they've even done tests with these like
i think free throw shooters or whatever
where they make them actually practice
free throws and the set of people
actually just imagine doing free throws
and apparently the ones who visualize
doing the free throws chord better in
the test than the ones who actually
practice the free throws because the
power of the mind it literally is
when you watch floyd do his pad work in
no way does that resemble a real fight
but he is creating those patterns isn't
he in his brain
so that when he is in a real fight he
everything will be perfect right yes
just faster and more intense and uh when
we're talking about the martial outside
of things i think that's why
you versus anderson was a beautiful
fight to watch i love it
it might not have happened it was boring
for some people i thought it was
beautiful it was saying there was two it
was two artists in there creating a
masterpiece yes
that was one of those fights for me like
the way
the way that fight
progressed it was just like it got worse
for him but at the same time he still
looked good he still looked like man i'm
hanging with the future of this division
you know i'm i'm able to hang in there
with you both won and yeah yeah exactly
not regarding and then the second round
he gave me he gave me trouble and he
almost tried to finish me and i had to
kind of like regroup myself because it
was an offbeat jab he was softball was
offbeat jab boom and i was like oh [__]
he got me that one boom oh he got me
another one [__] and he noticed it and
then i think he noticed it because i did
something to my eye and he's just you
know the spider he started trying to
like finish me
and yeah um that fight was just a
beautiful chess match a beautiful
exchange of
just that lingo that striking linger
between two
a master and a guy who was learning to
be a master you know and then the the
moment after the fight you know how he
just
pretty much just said you know this is
yours now
and that was just some like powerful
yeah beautiful moments and i was just
like oh my god yeah i didn't even know
how to contain myself in that moment
because it's for me it was like
um
kobe playing against jordan or ellen
iverson playing against jordan
because that's the guy i grew up
watching yep guy like looked at and i
was like man
i'm skinny and black i can [__] people
i want to be like that guy yeah i i want
to see like that fight i never thought
would materialize but when that
opportunity came
it was um after i fought brunson
and i went to ireland for my friend's
wedding
and
on the way to ireland i think or maybe a
week before and then they were like i
was meant to have this europe trip so
this is this is my first time in london
it's meant to happen
then 2019 or yeah 19 it was meant to
happen it just delayed well now i'm
finally here but i still don't regret it
i don't regret the chance to dance with
a legend like that like that's something
that i created a few iconic moments in
that fight like the obviously at the end
of the first round when i hit him with
the rocky stance
people were still like well i don't know
why you did that but somehow that's just
like the image boom
when you are inducted into the hall of
fame that'll be played it's just one of
those moments in it yeah and um and for
us as fans it was great as well because
to me
letting anderson silva go
is is is it's so sad you know because
yeah he created some of the most iconic
moments in mma history yeah and it was
almost like oh we can we can let him
retire now it's all right because we've
got the new guy yeah and it was it was a
great passing of the torch
um what i want to talk to you about the
the three kings because i've uh i've had
usman on my podcast oh yeah we've got
francis lined up so i'm collecting you
guys
and yeah i love this it's like some pro
wrestling thing it's so fun uh what is
it like being a part of something that's
iconic now
honestly it's
i'm able to be
could i could remove myself from
situation and look at it objectively
because
it's hard to sometimes when you're in it
you know when you can't you can't see
the forest for the trees because you're
so close to it right now
but i know
maybe
15 20 years from now they're gonna look
back on these times and be like [__]
hell
look at what these three did yeah in
their time when they were i mean there's
less than 20
i think less than 23 african fighters in
the ufc
far less than that and you've got three
of us that are champions at the same
time defending our belts and ruling our
divisions crazy with iron blackfist
dominant dominating yeah it's not like
you just someone flew the belt out of
nowhere we came in we took and that's
the thing that's beautiful i keep saying
like we're taking gold back to africa
and that's what we're going to do when
dana decides to put a show on
in one of the great countries of africa
you know one of the great countries
there but like it's just
in time right now i feel like they've
got the ball rolling because dana's
mentioned it a little bit more now
saying that you know he wants to get
this done before he's done with his
time in the game it has to be done oh
it's going to be there they're [__] up
with not having connor yeah do a stadium
in ireland dublin rather yeah he did not
he did the brandel fight in dublin but
it wasn't a stadium but he wasn't conor
then yeah like he was on the whale he
was i mean you look at the way that
crowd reacted after that ko you know
you know what would have happened in the
stadium
imagine like aldo versus conor two yeah
at the peak of that time
this place would have shut down and of
course obviously there's like i think
dean has a big box and fine and there's
the the rumble in the jungle and all of
that he wants to have a moment like that
it would be it'd be crazy not to do it
obviously some of that rests on i guess
francis and his contract situation
um
credit to francis the guy bet on himself
and and came away with everything
beautiful holds all the cards now so
they need to sign him without him
like i know you can put jones versus
steeper but no one's ever going to look
at them as the champion now of course
it'll be stupid every night sarah guns i
think he's the second best heavyweight
in the world
you know but if if somehow he becomes
the champions if francis leaves and it's
going to be like well
you know i mean everyone knows it's like
oh but francis beat him
so that's why i like what he said like
he holds all the cards now you know the
the balls in his court and yeah he's
going to play his way the fact that he
held his nerve as well when apparently
he was hit with a lawsuit on the way of
the year they're gone and also like
they were
they were playing some games with this
guy of course um he's got nerves of
steel
france and then he had knee injury as
well have you ever met him yet i haven't
no yeah when you meet him you'll realize
because he's a gentle giant he commands
so much
respect when he walks in a room but when
he speaks
you just know he's a big friendly guy
when he's your friend
yeah when he's your friend and yeah i've
not been fortunate enough not to be on
the receiving end of any of the other
stuff but yeah he's a guy that
because if i talk to him a week before
the fight we talked to the phone about
this kind of stuff
um and what he was going through and
also he let me know about his mcl and i
was like damn
but i never lost faith in him the whole
time i was like he's going to get this
done one way or another and then the way
he got it done was even more
with wrestling bully the guy who would
have thought yeah who would have thunk
it like the way he just took him down at
will when he was ripped him down as well
like
the first one is the guy uh cyril missed
a teep and then he caught it and his
black almost
body slammed him like some kind of
batista bomb or something it was crazy
man and then uh obviously there's um
camaro uzman who is reigning in the
welterweight division now knocking
people out looking like the complete
fighter levels um
it's fantastic to watch and um
i've seen separate footage of you guys
going back to africa i was actually i
looked at uh what khabib is doing in
russia starting his promotion
i was like if these three guys started a
promotion up in africa imagine yeah
there's a business that you guys could
create no i mean really sick just
putting that out there oh no don't worry
it's already been put out there yeah
francis is already like i said i talked
to him a week oh he's a smart guy yeah
we've we've talked about some things but
these need to know basis but um yeah
right now though what we're doing right
now is very important for the game
because like i said there's people that
that that look up to us from where we're
from
and they see themselves being
represented on the world stage and then
they realized like they can do this too
the thing is we have to do this and then
make it
a better a better playing field for them
when they come up so they don't get
taken advantage of
because there's not really much of a
ladder because you know francis's story
of how he escaped africa is is quite
something but obviously you and um
kamaru
grew up um in different countries after
moving
but you there needs to be a ladder for
these kids to apply their talent and
yeah what is it like when you you know
you're looking in these young kids eyes
and they're touching the belt and i seen
all this footage what is it like for you
when you see the way they're looking at
you does that hit you
it does in the moment it does hit me and
it's like it's
it's almost surreal because i'm just
like man these people look up to me in a
way that i'm like
it's back in the day there was a little
bit of imposter syndrome where it's just
like like why they
revere me this way like they don't know
me they don't and you kind of feel like
you don't deserve it you know what i
mean but then when the kids that do know
me
look up to me and
like there's um there's the kid from my
gym one of one of my um
i guess a friend his son who
who looks up to me harrison he he adores
me and i can see that
he is a kid that i
they're the ones that do this for him
you know i do this for all the other
everyone else who really appreciates me
and stuff but the ones that really know
me
because harrison uh spencer and zion i
believe that
those are the three kids
their dad still lets them watch me
even though i come across this way and
i'm not the most
fake or squeaky clean trying to act like
you know that kind of guy yeah and they
they appreciate me for me and they're
inspired by me
and like i said they look up to me i
i never want to let them down
i don't i'm not known as role model
because i think tupac said it best those
are two fake words playing a role being
a model
but [__] these these kid these kids are
like they're looking up to me in a sense
that like
i never want to let them down i never
want them to look at me and hang their
head in shame you know what i mean so
that's why i do what i do but still
doing it authentically me without
compromising myself because many people
are but you know these kids look up to
you i'm like oh
raise your own kids you know what i mean
i'm going to live my life if you don't
like the way i'm running things
let them find some new role models yeah
because i'm not no one's role model
because i've never been fake
ever i like the ring by the way oh yeah
thugs skull yeah i had that made in new
zealand mad thing yeah it was made by
those um i'll show you have a look those
you know those guys who've been covered
in tattoos and [__] yeah there's a few
of us yeah
they're like um
is it like part of a tribe or something
like that i think um oh no there's a few
of them are covered in tattoos yeah like
they've got tattoos on their faces and
[__] like that yeah
life after fighting ah have you thought
about that and what that involves yep um
the thing is i actually just want to
start a family that's me but um you had
any luck with the ladies no you're
struggling i think you're going to be
triggering it's hard man it's hard out
here in the floor man now i mean thing
is for me i what's your type to look at
like in terms of if we were a girl like
that's an other type no no type i don't
have a type people don't like i like
what i like but for me it's just not i
mean put it put it in my position like i
said i've
it's it's hard to find people who who
really want you i guess for you or want
to see you win and also have someone who
doesn't want to compete with you that's
the weird one i've had no because women
want to be the star of the show
generally no offense women but it's true
trust me when you have someone trying to
compete i'm like what this is not a
competition it's true you're trying to
be it's
[Laughter]
yeah it's never a competition and you
just
for me i i just want to be happy and i
want to be able to
like i don't want this kind of stress on
my family because i
i have okay so this kid right here right
he's my background this is camille
he's i'm like his uncle wow see it looks
good on me right
yeah being that being a dad looks good
on me but camille is is a is just the
gem of a kid because of his parents his
dad's a producer and his mom works from
home and they've spent pretty much his
whole life with him
very few days or maybe i'm gonna guess
less than three weeks away from him
and he's like four now you can't really
do that in the fight game now
while you're fighting yeah so you're
right i mean so i want to be don't and
you know the thing is the foundation i
see the difference i don't want to be
that dad that like
cool i'll be back
see you bye oh i don't want to be that
dad that like
you know uh the generic you know you
wake up at 7 00 am you say hi to your
kids and then you're off before they go
to school you come back home you spend
maybe an hour with them and then they go
to bed and then you know it compromises
the fighter as well we look at conor
mcgregor he's not been the same like in
that last fight in the weigh-in and he's
waving to his kids and he's just not in
that frame of mind of a killer whereas
like years ago he's screaming like a
psycho he's not waving to his kids
and i always when when he did that i was
like
because i know dustin's a family man but
some people find it easier to just to
switch off yeah and he was trying to do
both roles at the same time yeah i don't
think that was like if you want to talk
about the dark side like yeah this is
there's a place i have to go to like
everyone who who's close to me knows how
i am and people are like my mom has
accepted it now she she understands like
three weeks out from the fire if i'm not
picking up my her calls don't take it
personal they understand because i have
to kind of go bush within i start to
find myself disassociating
or detaching
from
my loved ones when i because i feel like
i'm going to war because you're going to
be in a reptilian state of mind yeah
right you can't be in that lovey hey mom
all the time yeah i just i'm not they
understand that my mom doesn't get
irritated or get taken personal so even
my dad they understand like okay he's
going to war and i don't like to see my
family too much before the fight
i never thought about that that's
interesting that's a good
good way to look at it but we'll find
out but yeah for me i just don't want to
have all this
[__] to deal with when i when i when i
do that i want to be able to be like
what do you want to do today and just do
whatever the [__] he or she wants to do
that day um apart from that i want to
have my own production company
definitely and i'm going to start some
crazy projects and want no i'm going to
work from home
just so i can because it's that
foundation man like i said camille is
just a lovely boy because
he just has a solid foundation and i can
tell that it's because the parents are
right there just instilling good just
solid morals and just love just love not
like absent and then just he's you know
off to a daycare or this or that but
yeah
those are two things i definitely want
to do in other things as well i want to
get into roller skating i don't know why
floyd does that you know yeah like but i
want to do it like say like you know a
guy like long beach griffy he's a
comedian on youtube and he doesn't know
where where you just dancing around
because i can dance so i'm like if i
could dance on skates i'd be sick didn't
you used to dance like i still do yeah i
just don't battle anymore but i ca i can
you know
i see you and romero doing a little uh
yeah oh that was a little something that
was light i barely tried the belt was
too heavy so you know i couldn't really
get it and get it off but you got the
belt with you no actually i don't even
carry it around
it's not really because i don't get
attached to it a lot of people you know
like example uh
kobe when he had
his belt he was walking around with it i
understand that i get it i did that a
couple of times but i just
ah look at that mike tyson you know this
is garbage this is
when he does that this is garbage
i don't think it's garbage yet because i
still think it's the significance of
that belt is important to me for what
i'm doing
but
i'm not attached to it i'm not attached
to it like to the sense where it's like
you know this is my identity this is all
i am you know i'm the champ you know i'm
like i don't care
that's healthy though i think you avoid
the pitfalls of a lot of champions when
you told you i've seen it all yeah you
realize to be like every time i fight
someone it's to challenge for the title
rather than
to i don't even have the belt with me
it's in it's whenever i'm gonna guess
it's in union's house somewhere
like in the box like uh whenever uh
maybe like when the camp starts that's
probably the last time i'll see the belt
i'll probably see it maybe when i get
home for some media stuff they'll be at
my house for a little bit but then when
the time when it's time for the next
camp then i just go back to the gym and
i'm like yep there you go and then
that's when that's when eugene knows
like
he switched
now it's time to
let's play the game when you were
talking earlier about having a family
and all of that and you're obviously
getting all this attention from these
girls and girls are going to look at you
so you're a prize you know
i'm a
[__] paycheck now absolutely happy
baby by me baby
before the baby come who the [__] cares
thank you rich oh my god it's true man
yeah that's what they're gonna look at
you like you've got that role
i'm not trying to get
trapped by no one yeah so how does a
girl separate herself from the pack to
prove that she isn't one of those
because that's tricky for them as well
yeah you try to give them game yeah i'm
trying to help some ladies out here yeah
i don't need this one of them's watching
and i'm going to give them the game
right now how do you trap izzy the stuff
yeah
uh but it must be hard to try because
you've got so many different women
asking wanting the same thing from you
and they're they're all just they're
just women so it's very hard to stand
out
yeah i guess what was the last thing a
girl did that you thought
that would be different you care
give a [__] like actually not really
trying to
find a way to care about what they're
gonna get out of it but actually just
giving a [__] just caring about someone
i think it's just
even just not about me it's just about
being nice caring about someone else
when i see that as someone even my
friends
if i see my friends when i see them just
showing love to each other it makes me
feel good inside and just like [__] i'm
so glad i'm part of this crew so yeah
but i'm gonna have to understand your
needs as well i'm guessing because your
life is so [__] complex oh yeah i'm
you know you can't be expected to just
be like they're back in cold or not yeah
definitely i've had that in the past
where someone's like i need to be the
most important thing in my in my
person's life that ain't happening right
now that's definitely not happening
right now
and yeah i'm just i'm i'm happy with
myself that's the thing first thing is
just being happy with myself
and being okay with where i'm at i'm not
trying to look for anything because if
you go looking around that's when you
find the wrong things trust me i've been
there before too
but at the moment i'm just happy where
i'm at i'm enjoying my freedom yeah and
i'm in london what's the things what's
the paintings like
is that a thing yeah that's the one yeah
what's the paintings like one of the
things that um my editor gio asked me to
ask you about because he's a huge fan of
you shadow geo uh conspiracy theories oh
tin foils do you uh where's the
are they listening yeah is anyone
listening they're going to get us is the
other side because you're a smart guy as
well you've got a science degree
something like that right
who said that computer science i did
computer graphic design so but i didn't
get my degree because i dropped out to
go be a ufc fighter or some [__] you
could make our thumbnails it worked out
all right yeah
um so any any conspiracy theories that
you're like you know what there might be
some truth on that you've got like the
moon landing 911 ah there's so many all
of these things well
[__] hell you want to go deep okay
put it this way
i'm a believer in some of them i've got
to admit like the start of this this
this this pandemic i was just like what
the [__] because i was i was scared oh
yeah so when the first lockdown hit
it felt like it felt like the purge and
i remember like new zealand was pretty
strict as well from very very strict
that's why we we kicked kova's ass and
then
we just delayed that yeah
look at us now the laughingstock of the
world
let's laugh at us again
that woman uh she and we're all like
this oh yeah we can have rmv 50 000
people yeah now look at us
um yeah we're behind now it's so stupid
like some of the some of the stuff
they're implementing but um
conspiracy theories look i know aliens
exist
i know definitely because even the the
fbi or whoever have been coming down
being saying like oh
we've been in possession of unidentified
flying objects for a few years now so
you know [__] that area 51 stuff you
have the um the guy who came out there
uh
talking about all the
the the crazy gravity
moving thing the way you explained it i
remember listening to that i was like
what the [__] and you know he's not
lying you know he believes what he's
saying
and i'm like there's a comedian i can't
remember which comedian said this the
best but he's like do you lie to your
kids
and everyone's like yes
is that why like to protect them it's
like what the [__] do you think the
government would do to protect you then
don't you think they'll lie to you about
a few things yeah maybe not everything
but there's a lot of pilots who've came
out and been like by the way i've i've
seen objects just move in ways that are
just it's just gone exactly yeah and uh
this look these go back to
1905 and show someone one of these and
then just play a video you'd be burning
the steak
you'd be a witch or a wizard or whatever
so there's there's things we don't
understand yet but because we we we we
haven't been
shown it so we can't fathom like this is
even possible like when bubblers i was
talking about you know putting a bowling
ball in the middle of a bed
um or mattress and then putting a marble
on one side and then it rolling down
that's how the force of this thing works
like it bends space and time that way
and i'm like
i i it's like mental parkour for me
because you know i can see parkour see
someone run on the roof and
poop gainer this and that but i can't
recreate it
i can just watch it and observe and i
understand what he's doing so when
someone like bob lazar or neil degrasse
tyson or jordan peterson is talking
about something i can
mentally just like i follow what you're
saying but then like i just try to
recreate what bubbles are said and i
probably butchered it but it's something
with a bowling ball in the bed and i
remember how we described it but it's
like mental parkour but it's because we
don't understand it when he says it
makes sense we try and recreate it
blah blah blah science and gravity bed
sheets or mattress and there are marbles
and you get the ball and it rolls down
the the aliens come out of the hole bro
yeah so but uh so i know aliens do exist
but when the start of this pandemic
happened yeah so i was i remember like
it was just felt like the purge even at
one point there was a there was a car
station wagon rolling by my house
blasting loud music
and i was just like i looked through and
as i locked the doors shut the windows
turn the lights off and i got my weapons
and stuff just getting ready because i
it was it was scary but then
a lot of the stuff
that i went down the rabbit hole on then
not everything came true but a lot of
the stuff now is like okay it's fact now
that this was this this this was made in
a in a lab in wuhan yep when i said that
i don't know 2020 people were like
stupid blah blah blah
and pangolins because [__] stan marsh
[__] the pangolin assumption in south
park but um yeah now this is fact but
the same people now oh do you i guess
it's facts do you have any reservations
about some of the security measures that
they're doing in regards to like uh id
cards and value of course they're not
going away new zealand and australia uh
they they some of the things we've seen
the cops doing over there
you know it made me go [__] going there
in my life yeah like
they didn't do much for tourism let me
tell you because i was like oh no back
in the day
like two years ago when it was on new
zealand clean and green beautiful yeah
yeah
that was that was the i want to go with
that now
we didn't ruin it the government
yeah so but um yeah like even now you
look at what's happening in wellington
in new zealand it looks like america in
2020.
like the cops are spraying people and
these riots and protests i was like well
we just delayed all this [__] that's
like the trickle-down effect somehow new
zealand's always slow like internet
explorer
is loading loading it's like yo catch up
like even now they're trying to
implement this whole thing with the
sit down at the table you can take your
mask off and when you get up you have to
put your mask on bro and it's like they
know that doesn't work anymore i don't
know why we're trying to why are we so
slow don't they have the internet these
old heads are they still using [__]
dial up windows 95 can't they catch up
but anyway
um
just yeah a lot of stuff that's
happening i just feel like it just the
whole vaccine cards thing it's
definitely
if it's for our safety there's there's
lots of there's lots of other ways you
can definitely our health health if it's
for our health there's a lot of other
things you can do to improve our health
but you look at what they're doing in
china now with um
social credit scores you know these are
things i don't know if you're aware of
where it's like if you
um
buy uh
i think what they did they put something
out recently in canada that if you
they can stop your bank transactions or
your your bank account like that if you
say
fund uh uh like a gofundme for some
protester exactly so those lorry driving
uh lorry drivers if you funded them yeah
you can just shut your bank account
without a quick warning with what you
don't need anything
nothing you don't need proof that's
crazy like that is that's where we're at
right now say that in 2020 people be
like oh you're [__] kidding now
they'll [__] never do that and now
look this is like something that's
happening now in canada they've just
kind of said that but it's gonna trickle
down and then it's all this is what
happens when people wanna
they've done this so many times in
history when you wanna take people's
rights to where you just push a little
bit so they get fed up and you stop
there and then when they go back to
doing their things you push a little bit
more in the ah you always do it in the
name of safety yeah as well always this
is for your own good but who
from from who from what yeah from them
unfortunately who's them is that the new
pronouns
they them z [__] we can't we can't we
can't win crazy times man you've been
watching anything good on netflix lately
me
tender swindler
honestly so i've watched it but my guys
haven't watched it yet so we've been
trying to watch it this whole trip
because i want to watch it again i said
to them i was like yo this is [__]
it's crazy i don't know how this guy
pulled it off and he's a piece of [__]
for doing it but
i am impressed
i can't lie i don't express i'm like we
got a million the men got one back i
don't know but i don't know how i'm like
i'm still like he's a piece of [__] like
cause some of the ladies like he put
them in debt and he's not spent any jail
time oh no because that's another thing
he's borrowed money he's free i don't
understand and then somehow he's just
and he's now got a hollywood agent that
he's trying to do a dating show from
whatever he's doing
you know where they do the camera
yep yep and he's just bought ferrari
this guy he's he's a villain he's
actually like a legit villain a super
villain even even on his whatsapp
messages you're like this guy sounds
like scarface yeah yeah like he's got
that homeless king or some [__] he said
it but i'm just like yeah like when he's
like hey baby
it sounds like he's got some kind of
bible oh yeah you can tell he's just
like he's and then we were sending her
those messages like unanswered like baby
please call me you know i'm like oh my
god but somehow again i'm impressed and
i'm impressed in the sense that i don't
know how he got it how we got away with
it it's like well it's agreed isn't it
it's like it's when you sell the dream
to someone i just feel like those women
were so
hell-bent on this is my one opportunity
to become a multi-millionaire this is
how you get trapped i give them
everything i get yeah
and i imagine by the time they're on
like the third or fourth loan they've
taken out they're like if i stop now
that means it's not real so i'm just
gonna keep going because i can't it's
almost like some people when they're in
a cult and they realize they [__] up
but they're like no i can't i'm so
intolerant you're gonna stick with them
all those of my beliefs i don't care
what anyone says yeah so you're right
now he had a system he'll he this is one
of the best ways of manipulation from
what i've seen
in my experience is emotional
manipulation talking to heartstrings so
he got them in there with the whole love
thing my enemies
my enemies are after me
i made a little [__] thing
we tried to get one of the the ladies on
the podcast we were inquiring and they
were like
uh no questions at all about why did
they not realize in time and i'm like
the entire documentary at no point did
you say uh any of these women
why did you do this like it wasn't even
put them it was just like we were in
love that's what all responsibility from
these 30 odd year old women is just
taken away and i understand they're
victims but at the same time like come
on yeah at least that's the [__]
question but everyone's dancing around
the elephant in the room which is we
were gonna get rich
yeah what i mean nice i mean like i said
he saw them a dream i don't even know
how he got his
those photoshopped images those pages
online whatever but he got it somehow
and he already had a system in place so
it's like a virus he would latch on to a
host siphon them up horrible sapphin
them up and then eventually when he's
done siphoning that up then cool
detach and then find a new host and then
yeah like i said he's a piece of [__]
but at the same time i can't lie i'm
impressed and that i know they might
come for me for that but hey bring the
smoke
we got to wrap this up now because uh
izzy's got a lot of things to be getting
on with in london you've got to see the
paintings and um and the bridge and uh
it feels like it's 5 p.m yeah
these windows are tinted oh okay i see
[__] i was like we got dark production
bro
um but one last question how would you
like to be remembered ooh
a good [__] a guy who was just in here
having fun
doing his thing for everyone and left
with a smile on his face and a lot of
money [__] load of [__] loads of money a
new contract yes and uh yeah thanks very
much mate you're an absolute legend
appreciate it huge fan can't wait to see
all your next fights and uh yeah don't
forget to subscribe there's the uh
style bender on youtube one of the best
youtube channels growing right now we're
only a year strong and we're blowing up
thousand and uh that's like 700 800
right now is that we're going up almost
a milli god oh my man
straight away yeah uh yeah subscribe
easy thanks for watching we'll see you
later cheers